good Seychelles a tropical Eden but
below the surface this is no paradise
conservationist from nature Seychelles
took us to coos an island once this reef
would have been teeming with vibrant
fish now it's been reduced to rubble the
coral killed by warming seas most of the
fish long gone algae is taking over a
passing eagle ray pauses to feed before
it too moves on a coral graveyard that's
a sure sign of climate change too
bleaching events in the past few decades
one in 1998 and one in 2016 both of
which caused significant Kroll mortality
which has led to ongoing reach a
gradation
it's horrible to imagine that this is
happening in many other reefs around the
world it's not just what we're seeing
here the Seychelles is going to be
affected in many of the islands and the
bleaching event is likely to affect
other areas too just a rise of one or
two degrees is enough for coral to turn
a ghostly white bleaching that becomes
fatal unless the water cools but this is
also an opportunity nature Seychelles is
selecting the survivors growing
fragments on ropes than cementing them
on the seabed twenty four thousand
transplants so far in an area the size
of a football field the beginnings of a
more heat-resistant reef already fish
are returning but it is just a
short-term fix what we're trying to do
is maintain that ecosystem function
whilst the world gets its act together
and global corporations and governments
start to actually make the changes which
are necessary to really combat climate
change we should be a moral obligation
for ourselves to make the choices and
make the decisions that are necessary to
solve that problem it is vital work a
quarter of all marine life depends on
coral reefs
but the spikes in water temperature are
becoming more common satellite
observations show that warm water is
once again spreading across the Indian
Ocean and is expected to arrive here in
the Seychelles in the coming weeks with
a significant risk of coral bleaching
but scientists just don't know what's
happening in the deeper water around
algebra 600 miles away because the reefs
have been out of reach until now the
nekton mission will use submersibles to
survey the coral beyond the reach of
scuba divers and our deep ocean Live
programs will follow the scientists down
but the coral gardeners of nature say
shells are doing whatever they can in
the shallows offering some hope in a
warming ocean Tamas more Sky News in the
Seychelles